tant'è oggi vado a creare uno slide
gigantesco unendo tutti i miei slime
comprati e fatti in casa tra cui questa
era già uno smile multi ve lo ricordate
qua dentro già in questo club di gant se
avete visto il video gloss lines dante
sapete che slime è questo quindi andrò
unire tutti questi strani dentro questi
slime gigantesco diventa e vediamo
quanto diventa grande quanto pesa
sventerà una sorta di piscina di slime
quindi mi raccomando se volete vedere
cosa succede come sono tutti questi
slime guardate il video fino alla fine
lasciati un bel live se volete vedere
altri esperimenti posti di slime 10.000
l'ocst andrò fare altri esperimenti
fossi con gli slime mettetevi comodi
prendete i pop corn prendete le patatine
prendete il tè il caffè perché questo
video sarà epico perché creerò lo slime
più grande che abbia mai fatto e non ho
idea che si lavori tutti
iniziamo subito sostenuti di ancora
iscritti volete entrare a far parte
della stu risparmi che vi basta
iscrivervi attivare le notifiche
cliccando nella campanellina lasciare un
like su questo video e seguirmi su
instagram è su facebook il mio nome su
instagram su facebook è sempre amica
stories
siete pronti iniziamo subito allora
innanzitutto vediamo un momento come
diventa su questo perché le bolle dalla
superficie sono tutte sparite o vittima
fosse grande
ma vediamo facciamo un po di pochi
dobbiamo a girarlo vediamo se è rimasto
lucido e lucidissimo lo si allora
iniziamo con gli slime fatti da me
questo ve lo ricordate era una sorta di
slime in cui tagliamo tutti gli scrissi
vediamo come diventate alibi per mero
mestrale è stranissimo con la
trasparente è rimasto comunque dire che
non si è indurito però trovano oggi è
diventato un po psicosi il merito per
niente però guarda te che strada
no
che mettiamolo dentro ok abbiamo
aggiunto il primo line fatto in casa il
minestrone
vediamo un po come stilisti ottimiste
nessuno
[Musica]
troppo curioso di vedere come diventerà
prossimo slime fatto in casa questo
ruolo 3 con i coriandoli vediamo come è
diventato oggi io questo mese cosa può
sembrare e polenta
vediamo un po
[Musica]
però mi piace bella consistenza
andiamo ad aggiungere anche in questo
oggi e korea milano un po rovinato
purtroppo ragazzo bello
[Musica]
addio devo mischiarlo oggi è già
stranissimo questo flying vediamo band
gialloverde come fumetto si sentono
investite questo che il prossimo live
fatto in casa sinceramente non mi
ricordo penso fosse una sorta di biopic
trans in un quadro che ne era quello che
avevo fatto da bendata sembra anche
bello
vediamo un po diventata si può zucchero
filato qua le palline stanno un po
staccando grossi diventato tipo glossy
bellissimo
[Musica]
ok aggiungiamo anche questo
vediamo un po prossimo slide
non ho idea di che sliven sia questo è
la gomes al contrario per non fargli
prendere aria ma vi giuro che non mi
ricordo di aver fatto nessuno sly il
verde non so se con il tempo ha cambiato
colore comunque vediamo
oddio my super grossi guai
che strano questo colore davvero non ho
mai fatto una splendida stato non
capisco che sulla imposta all'inizio
profilo è diventato super glossy di temi
nei commenti a voi piace questo colore
un po particolare wow 40 piccolo si
cappello
[Musica]
via diamolo nel minestrone andiamo un po
mischiarle crediamo ma o non vedo l'ora
di vedere come diventerà tutto mischiato
produttivo slime questo è il gelli cubes
line vediamo un po come diventato tanta
gente è passato un sacco di tempo quindi
non so proprio come sarà adesso
oddio coratti tutte le spugne te perché
tra l'altro avevo rischiato due tipi di
spugnette ha dato tutto verde lucido
vediamo un po oddio fa ancora dei suoni
di un po rigido via buttiamolo oddio
quanto peserà questo fly mood poi
prossimo slime questo era un mix di
altri slam quindi questo no fly mood
minuti lo stesso
vediamo un po come addio termine
ancora vari suoni smr e un po psicosi
via buttiamo anche questo allora
prossimo è praticamente simile a quello
di prima perché li avevo messi in due
contenitori
vediamo se anche questo è diventato
blues in quanto polizia
capello è diventato glossy anche questo
nuova bella sensazione di battere le
mani questo tanti slam pazzesca vorrei
farmelo toccare allora prossimo sempre
quello zona con i coriandoli perché
l'hanno divisa finanze contenitori
perché le norme se vi ricordate un brano
sembra una frittata
oddio guardate l'importanza di usare dei
contenitori buoni sul contenitore non è
buono per niente infatti lo slime
strabordato seppure un diritto guardate
che strano
wow
questo è lo so anche che posso vedere da
poco che ho comprato su ali express che
fa in questa mattina fastidiosissima
questo innanzitutto pizzicato maledetto
ragazzi curate quanti colori wow
ora vado ad aggiungere un altro flames
muti
non so se ve lo ricordate dall'altra in
studio dal video con il mio ragazzo che
è assurdo questo va beh a parte che pesa
tantissimo guardate che consistenza
strana che ha ceduto grigio sotto è più
morbido e allungabile anche un po di
twitter comunque a me è sembrato cemento
proprio così come è sotto e ti amo
dobbiamo ammetterlo al contrario oddio
udc pesa tantissimo
vediamo wow
però fa dei super rumori ha consistenza
e finissima
[Musica]
ciao
vabbè troppo bella e marcello ma di qua
ora continuiamo a mettere gli altri e
slide poi andiamo a mischiare tutto
[Musica]
uova a tenere questi servizi il filo
quando sembra che aveva mischiato 2
skifidol ma nome ricorda con che cosa
infatti guardate molto più morbido wow
questo infatti è rimasto mobile anche un
po più succoso perché leggo mischiato
con un altro slime
no perché sterminò perché verde
fosforescente
[Musica]
oddio qua pensavo non ci fosse niente
mentre invece quello trasparente
guardate
terra
[Musica]
arrivato
oddio anche questo l'aveva misurato con
un altro skifidol vi ricordate infatti
non è proprio il fianco e tipo un mezzo
dorato in fatto
per fare questo
google secondo come piatto guardate
fatto quest'anno
ciao ragazzi guardate quanti colori e
quanto è grande non essere anche oggi è
pesantissimo
siete curiosi di vedere di che colore
diventa o penali mischiamo tutti si
vedevano nei commenti secondo voi di che
colore diventerà e vediamo chi indovina
scrivetelo adesso e ora iniziamo
mischiare il tutto wow ha tantissime
consistenze perché ci sono botte slide
losties live transit fly mood è
bellissimo vorrei farvi immergere le
mani qua dentro perché è però un pò figo
e da per lo spam più grande che abbia
mai fatto
abbiamo mischiare di tutto vediamo che
suoli farà poi tipo super morbido che
ben suoli quelle mani sprofondano dentro
di me quanto riesco a farli sprofondare
per dare mai per sempre dentro lo slide
oddio se rimangono tipo incastrata
dentro le mani po faticosa da rischiare
tutto effettivamente che anch'io slime
guardati con titolari ci sono già solo
in questo prefetto esistono tipo iii
slime 7 suoni pazzeschi
[Musica]
oddio quest'arte che strano è un mix di
quattro slime questo tiro e lo strappo
sotto ci sono altri colori in ogni pezzo
ci sono colori diversi tipo destava
vista perché si chiama proviamo a
riemergere la mischiano tutto e poi
vediamo se alla fine dopo che lo abbiamo
visto tutto riusciamo a ritrovarlo
vediamo grazie troppo bello emergeva
ripetette vorrei farmelo trovare anche
voi vorrei farmelo toccare
[Musica]
per questa scusa se trovo qualcosa di
strano partenza quando guarda tutti gli
altri schemi che si stanno inglobando
tipo
sembra che si formino le tasche tv qua
dentro ora se questo fatti è
presentissimo
[Musica]
che ne pensa a un sacco di cose stessero
strano notare che quanto è pesante
proprio a strapparlo e scoprirai tanti
colori dentro chiuse in incastrati in
ogni pezzo c'è una sorpresa i magistrati
a strati no prati e sorprese cercola
cosa cosa dio odino come solo i costi
perché in queste sono più duri non si
mischiano bene quindi escono poi trovati
qua fatti sembrano però ogni o full o un
colore diverso grado di strappare no no
no no questo problema proviamo io tiro
da una parte tutto all'altra vediamo
come si stratta
[Applauso]
oddio carrara ancora dentro
[Musica]
no vabbè questo diritto
no è veramente finissimo prime create
più strappo feste rivelano nuove cose
dentro slime turbine tutti io gli
elastici corse gli elastici qua ancora
slime è vero ci sono questi trend più
duri che sono rimasti intatti non si
mischiano proprio che questi tirarli
fuori proprio pensi tutto il rosa
addio è assurdo però ogni pezzo di pasta
ben diverso se qualcosa di cui proviamo
a continuare a mischiano stessi riesco
ritrovano le cose più strane infatti
questo è un diamantino o forse perché
non lo mischiato ancora bene vediamo
primo qua vediamo proviamo quadretto
oddio quale ha sempre mostrato un
ingrandimento
c'è proprio di tutto per destra
stracciamo secondi
se in superficie rimane verde ma dentro
rimane tipo mille colori color tornando
in superficie sono dentro
mio figlio è doveroso e più assurdo che
abbiamo il porto che il nome dovrei dare
a questo slime scrivetelo nei commenti
sto pensando slime sorprese astratti o
qualcosa del genere tipo che forse per
questo vi toccherà la spugnetta del
zeligtube obiettivo rimasto è rimasta
quasi intatta primi commenti che non mi
dovrei dare a questo schlein pezzo di
cannuccia se doveva di tutto perfetto
vediamo pre all ultimo vediamo cosa
troviamo lo fosse ritroviamo 40 mo
vediamo se riusciamo a ritrovarlo si no
fatemi sapere league un 27 è piaciuto
questo slide smoothie lasciate un bel
like vediamo se riusciamo a raggiungere
10.000 l'aics farò altri esperimenti
fatti con lo slime mi raccomando se non
siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi e attivate le notifiche se
non attivate le notifiche molti dei miei
video non vi appariranno quindi i fatti
ma se le notifiche persone sicuri di
vederli tutti essere i primi a vederli
ora qua quattro case lines cui potete
cliccare potete vedere i miei altri
video slime oppure le mie challenge home
video divertente io video rilassanti smr
scegliete pure una di queste quattro
caselline è un buona visione
un bacione a tutti